Once, there was a chef, who was mean to his cooks.
He was mean to the people who came in to eat.
He charged too much for meals.
Many people were not able to afford the cheapest bean dish.
When his metal oven broke, he did not have it fixed.
So everything baked in it burned.
The only light was from candles and the whole place was a mess.
Sometimes, he didn't pay his waiters.
Since they had no funds, they had many debts.
The chef behaved this way all the time.
He monitored the cooks and yelled if they did not do things his way.
One day, the cooks decided that they were tired of the abuse...
...and that they would not be passive anymore.
Everyone opposed the chef.
At first, they thought about suing him.
Instead, they tied up the chef with rope.
Now, they controlled the restaurant!
They decreased the price of food.
They used the best ingredients and made large quantities of food.
They turned on the lights.
The restaurant was converted into a happy place.
For the first time, many people came to eat.
The chef realized that the restaurant's problems were his fault.
The chef learned an important lesson.
The new, generous chef insisted on giving the customers a free meal.